Hello ! Donc
je voulais faire une vidéo qui était
très quick de même que j'ai pensé mais
bon c'était juste ma ma réflexion
pendant que je cuisinais que je voulais
que je voulais partager.
Ouais, c'est ça. Dans le fond,
j'écoutais le le podcast de Tony Robbins
avec
Ormoi
puis euh on parlait du
de créer quelque chose de sa vie qui est
plus grand que soi.
Puis euh
entre autres ce qui m'a accroché
làdedans que je voulais parler c'était
je sais pas sûr que vous l'avez déjà
vécu fond que tout le monde déjà vécu
mais peut-être pas que ça été autant
important pour chacun mais c'est dans ta
vie comme
desénergie
qui vient naturellement
de de projets de choses qui t'allum
Puis
des fois c'est fou là, des fois c'est
comme tu vas te réveiller pendant la
nuit parce que tu as une idée de tel sur
tel projet puis des fois et des fois ça
vient très rapidement puis tu as des
feelings de comme
de création genre parce que tuas un
projet qui t'allume genre
tu sais moi rapidement comme ça j'en ai
des fois ça m'arrivé
c'est principalement dans dans dernières
années peut-être des fois des
opportunités des business, des fois des
petites choses, des fois des
opportunités, des fois des rencontres,
des fois des choses qui m'allumaient au
niveau business que genre des projets
qui m'allumaient genre
par exemple de travailler sur une
application puis là on commença à
travailler sur l'application puis là
finalement on commence à travailler
dessus pu on se rend compte du potentiel
de l'application par que là on continue
à travailler dessus là on on réfléchit
puis là les idées viennent naturellement
naturellement tu es comme alimenté sur
ce projet là puis euh
ça te donne de l'énergie genre c'est
comme si tu un énergie en de toi qui
vient sans que tu l' demandé sans que tu
as plus dormi ou peu importe tuas rien
fait de différent la seule affaire c'est
que tuas un projet t'allume bien
que tuas pas besoin d'avoir une
motivation pas besoin d'avoir peorte
pour travailler dessus ça vient
naturellement genre même si tu fais pas
ça
les idées viennent puis tu es comme tu
as du plaisir à réfléchir à ça genre ça
vient naturellement genre
là je dis énormément genre parce que
c'est comme un peu pas abstrait mais tu
sais c'est comme pas c'est comme c'est
pas concret
c'est pas de la théorie que je vous dis
là c'est comm vraiment au niveau du du
senti
que je suis comme beaucoup en mode je
dis des gens genre ça mon de langage
En tout cas,
mais où c'est que je l'en
c'est qu'il faut le trouver ça il faut
le trouver
c'est comme s'il faut c'est comme si
quand tu n
toute ta vie tu vas avoir cette énergie
comme si
3 ton énergie des fois plus que ça
t'allume une
de ça genre
ben c'est faut que tu trouves que tu
soit tu notes toutes les moments que ça
t'arrive genre toutes les moments aussi
que e ce moment là je me sentais là e
full d'énergie on m'a parlé de ce
projetlà là ça m'a allumé j'ai eu plein
d'idées j'ai eu plein eu de je réfléchis
à ça là je travaille là-dessus ça me
demandait pas d'énergie ça m'en donnait
d'énergie fait de travailler là-dessus
ça me donnait de l'énergie puis de
toutes les noter toutes noter les
moments aussi dans ta vie que tu resses
cette énergie là qui monte en toi pu tu
es comme j'ai goû faire 10000 affaires
en lien avec ce projet là plein d'idées
plein d'énergie plein de tuas le goû de
travailler dedans puis ça vient
naturellement toutes les notés voir
c'est quoi les c'est quoi les les
corrélations entre elles c'est quoi les
choses mettons je sais pas moi c'était
quelquun d'artistique mais est-ce que
c'était en peut-être que toi c'est tout
ce qui est au niveau du théâtre quand tu
commences travailler sur des projets de
théâtre d'écriture, je sais pas moi,
puis tu as full d'énergie à faire ça,
puis tu as plein d'idées qui viennent
naturellement mais comme notl ça,
peut-être que c'est de l'écriture
justement, peut-être que c'est puis là
tu es dans un autre contexte, tu es plus
au niveau je sais pas l'école ou peu
importe puis là c'est peut-être je sais
pas encore une fois tu création
artistique ça puis de juste aller aller
trouver tous ces moment dans ta vie
aussi que tu as eu cette énergie là qui
est venu en dedans de toi pour apprendre
à te connaître puis voir crim c'est où
dans ma vie où c'est que je suis le plus
naturellement là
genre plein d'énergie, plein de euh de
de de vouloir
de le trouver, trouver quelque chose que
au final, je pense que c'est beaucoup en
lien avec ton trouver ton trouver tes
tes forces trouver aussi avec des gens
avec qui que que tu aimes travailler
fait je pense que quand tu rel comme les
trois fait le monde avec qui tué le
projet que tu fais slash le why de
pourquoi tu le OK. Puis
le un sentiment d'efficacité puis
d'apprentissage derrière quand tu réunis
les trois comme une sorte d'équigère on
pourrait dire c'est là que l'énergie
vient naturellement
puis je trouve tellement de monde dans
leur vie qui ont pas trouvé ça parce que
c'est quand même t trouver c faut tu un
travail de réflexion ok ces momentsl
même si c'est des moments qui sont très
rapides ben les identifier faire la
corrélation voir c'est où que toi tu
Au c'est comme tu trouves ton ton X, ton
ik toutes des affaires que on parle
souvent mais c'est en expérimentant
différentes choses, tu sais, des choses
différentes dans des contextes
différents avec des gens différents que
tu vas trouver une corrélation entre
plein de choses.
Puis
je pense ça devrait être un peu comme
notre quête de vie
de ça de mais comme je pense ça devrait
être un peu notre quête de vie de
trouver
la corrélation tout ça puis de voir ok
peut-être que moi c'est en enseignement
que je suis full alimenté full d'énergie
puis je suis full passionné c'est moi
c'est peut-être en écriture c'est moi
c'est peut-être en en artistique en
peinture peut-être en business peut-être
en gestion de projets sais trouver
l'énergie qui est comme
qui vient de nulle part
mais trouver à bien d'où tu sais puis le
pourquoi est là puis
je pense c'est une des manières de
devenir épanoui dans ce que tu fais
parce que tu te sens bon efficace des
gens que tuaimes environnement aussi que
c'est
propice à ça je sais pas un projet aussi
qui t'allume
fait que qu'est-ce que je pourrais dire
c'est va expérimenter 10000 affaires, va
expérimenter 10000 affaire des projets
va travaer avec des mondes des personnes
différentes dans des contextes
différents va voyager aussi voyager ça
permet de goûter à plein de choses puis
de voir c'est quand est-ce que ça l'
bien cette énergie là dans des contextes
qui sont complètement différents. Puis
c'est de même, je pense que tu vas avoir
une vie qui est euh
qui est épanouie sur ton X. Puis aussi
quand tu es dans ce dans ce moment-là
aussi tu es d'énergie comme ça là e
c'est euh tu es tellement plus efficace,
tu es tellement toutes les cellules de
ton cerveau fonctionnent.
C'est ça. Tu es tu es full efficace. Tu
es genre le tu as ton sumomum
d'efficacité puis de productivité, de
proactivité aussi, de réflexion,
d'idéation. ta créativité au max fait
que
ouais je pense que pour être épanoui
dans ta vie pour vivre ta vie à ton
plein potentiel
par l'aventure puis va trouver moment
dans ta vie que
cette énergie donc ciao Yeah.